Transcriber: Abd alrahman shiban
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
إذا جئت لأعرّفكم بنفسي؛
أنا علا سليمان الشعار،
خريجة اقتصاد من جامعة دمشق.
خريجة مركز أدهم اسماعيل
للفنون التشكيلية.
ألعب رياضة لأحافظ على جسمي ورشاقته
مثل أغلب الصبايا الموجودات في القاعة.
ستقولون لي: “أهلاً وسهلًا“.
لكن إذا رجعت وعرّفتكم أني بطلة عرب
حاصلة على المركز الثالث بالبطولة العربية
في أبوظبي للمواي تاي،
أو،
الملاكمة التايلاندية
أو مثلما نقول لها هنا “قتال شوارع“.
تمامًا!
هذه هي ردة الفعل التي تعودت عليها،
يمكن لأنني صبية ولست شاب صبي،
يمكن لأنكم تفتشون
إذا عندي عضلات ولم تجدوها،
أو يمكن أن تقولوا: “ما هذا” لديك عضلات!
وهذا يؤثر سلبًا على أنوثتك.
أو يمكن لأنني مُحجبة؟
حسنًا، ماذا تعني المواي تاي؟
المواي تاي هي ملاكمة تايلاندية الأصل،
وتسمّى لعبة التسعة أسلحة
والتي نستخدم فيها القبضتين
والكوعين والركبتين،
والقدمين وأخيرًا التَماسك.
على فكرة، اللعبة ليست سهلة
وتعتبر رابع أخطر لعبة في العالم.
تم ابتكار هذا الفن القتالي
في القرن السادس عشر
لتدريب الجنود على القتال في تايلاند.
بدأت عندنا في سوريا عام 1996،
يعني يمكنم القول قبل 26 عامًا.
عندما تم إرسال بعثة إلى لبنان
لتعلّم أساليب اللعبة
لعبها القليل عندنا.
واختفت اللعبة خلال الحرب.
وتم حظرها بسبب خطورتها.
لتعود في عام 2019
ضمن قرار رسمي من الاتحاد الرياضي.
اللعبة تحتاج إلى قوة، سرعة، لياقة
واحترام للخصم.
يمكن القول أنها ليست لعبة صعبة
في حال تعلّمنا المبادئ.
ولكن بحال اتجهنا للاحتراف
فهي ستأخذ منحى الخطورة
لماذا؟ لأننا سنلعب دون ارتداء الواقيات.
وهي: واقية رأس، واقية صدر، واقية قصبة
وأهمها واقية الأسنان،
وأخيرًا واقية المكثر.
غريبة، أليس كذلك!
حسنًا، ما هي قصتي مع المواي تاي؟
هذا يا سادة،
أنا علا الصبية اللطيفة
التي طوال عمرها لم تتوقع أن تضرب أحد،
أو حتى أن تتلقى ضربة من أي إنسان.
المهم، في السنة الثانية،
حضرت دورات تدريبية
لمهارات مختلفة
والتي كانت تتضمن
تصميم مبادرات يقوم فيها الشباب
بهدف تفعيلهم بالمجتمع بمجالات مختلفة،
تناقشنا وطُرحت آراء وأفكار
و من ضمنهم صبية وقفت وقالت:
“لماذا لا نتعلم الدفاع عن النفس؟”
أيّدنا الفكرة
بدافع الحماس لشيء غريب،
لأننا كنّا في ذلك الوقت في عام 2017،
وكانت هنالك تبعات للحرب،
فإذا تعلمنا بعض الحركات،
سنستفيد منها كسلاح كوننا نحن الإناث
لأي مشكلة تواجهنا في الشارع،
في العمل،
وفي طريق العودة إلى المنزل،
من مبدأ:
درهم وقاية خير من قنطار علاج.
وتم الاتفاق مع مدرب على تدريب
مدته أربعة أيام.
الشيء الذي دفعني أنا شخصيًا
هو الفضول البحت.
وأصبحت فورًا أتخيل نفسي أنا الصبية
التي تعتمد على نفسها دون الاستناد على أحد.
وانتهى التدريب،
وبدأ المدرب يدربنا على ملاكمة الركل.
تخيلوا، كان معنا صبية عمرها 50 سنة.
في البداية، عندما كنّا نراها،
كنّا نستغرب وجودها،
لكن بعد ذلك،
أصبحت تعطينا دافع أكبر للاستمرار.
أصبحنا نتكلم عنها في كل مرة
يسألنا بها أصدقاؤنا وعائلاتنا
ماذا تردن من وراء هذه الرياضة؟
في الواقع،
لنعترف أننا كنّا نمر بظروف وتحديات صعبة
تجعل الواحد منّا أحيانًا
يعيد التفكير في ترتيب أولوياته
بالإضافة إلى أنه لم يكن هناك أبدًا تشجيع
من البيئة المحيطة على هكذا خيار غريب.
لكن في كل مرة كنت أقف وأتكلم للناس
بشغف عن الشيء الذي أقوم به،
لا أحد كان يتحمس أو يهتم!
بالواقع،
والدي الوحيد الذي كان يشجعني،
وكان بنفسه يأخدني إلى البطولات
وينتظرني حتى الانتهاء.
يمكن نحن لسنا بحاجة
إلى أكثر من شخص واحد
يشجعنا،
يحترم اختيارنا.
ومن بعدها حصلت على:
المركز الأول في بطولة ملاكمة الركل،
المركز الثالث في بطولة
الجمهورية لملاكمة الركل.
وفي عام 2019، تمّ إقرار رياضة المواي تاي
كرياضة رسمية معترف فيها في سوريا.
وهنا كانت النقلة النوعية،
انتقلتُ إلى رياضة المواي تاي
بعدما كنتُ أتدرب على ملاكمة الركل.
عندما بدأ الجد،
وبدأ الشغف يكبر أكثر وأكثر،
سمعت عن بطولة عربية
مقامة في مدينة أبوظبي.
شاركت في مباريات الانتقاء،
تمَّ اختياري في فئة وزن 60 كيلوغرام.
سفر، بطولات، إنجازات.
تخيلوا، إنها المرة الأولى
التي أسافر بها في حياتي!
أول مرة أحضر فيها هكذا فعالية ضخمة!
هكذا تنظيم! وهكذا عدد من اللاعبين!
كان هنالك 113 لاعب ولاعبة،
من كل البلاد العربية.
وأنا كنت واحدة منهم.
حصلنا على ميداليتين برونزيتين،
أنا من فئة 60 كيلوغرام،
وزميلي علي من فئة 75 كيلوغرام،
ورفعنا اسم سوريا
في البطولة العربية للمواي تاي
بعد مرور ثمانية أعوام
على عدم مشاركتها بسبب الحرب.
وكوننا أبطال،
كان هنالك لقاءات تلفازية،
في أبوظبي،
وفي سوريا عند عودتنا.
وانتشر الخبر بالجرائد الرسمية.
مَن كان يتوقع حصول هذا الشيء،
وحدوثه بهذه السرعة ووصوله لهذه الأماكن؟
لكن!
بسبب خيار غريب اتخذته،
بدافع الفضول!
لشيء لم أفكر طوال حياتي فيه، أو عرفت عنه.
فقط لأنني وثقت في نفسي،
وأعطيت نفسي فرصة البداية فيه والتجربة.
دعوني أحدثكم عن تأثير المواي تاي على نفسي،
ماذا أضافت لي كشخص وكأنثى.
إلى صحتي: لياقة، قوة.
أصبحت أهتم بنفسي، بأكْلي،
أقسّم وجباتي بين بروتين،ألياف،نشويات
أخاف على نفسي من الأكْل الدسم والسكريات.
هل تعرفون ماذا حصل لشخصيتي؟
انقلبت شخصيتي 180 درجة!
من علا الصبية الخجولة
التي لا تسمعون منها حرف،
من فتاة قادمة من بيئة محافظة جدًا جدًا،
من مجتمع لا يسمح
للفتاة بكثير من الأشياء لفعلها
فقط لأنها فتاة،
إلى علا،
إلى علا التي تحب أن تتكلم
وتجرّب وتناقش وتطرح رأيها
وتعبّر عن مشاعرها دون خوف أو خجل.
حسنًا،
مهنيًا، ماذا استفدت من هذه الرياضة؟
مهنيًا، استفدت منها عندما
كنت أعمل في صالة أفراح
وهذا العمل كان يتطلب مني
الرجوع متأخرة إلى البيت،
وكان من المستحيل موافقة عائلتي على هالشيء،
أو أن أقدر على القيام به، لأنني فتاة.
حتى رفيقاتي أصبحن يقلن لي:
“يا علا انتظرينا سنرجع معك،
في حال حدوث أي شيء، تكوني موجودة“.
يتكلمن مع عائلاتهن ويخبروهم أن لا يخافوا
لأنهن سيعدن مع علا.
اليوم أصبحت معروفة ضمن المجتمع الرياضي؛
علا الفنانة الرياضية التي رفعت اسم سوريا
في البطولة العربية للمواي تاي.
أصبح يُذكر اسمي في محافظات
أنا لا أعرف بها أحد.
أصبحت أطمح للأفضل.
أرغب في أن أكبر،
وأن أشارك في بطولات عالمية،
أريد أن أطور نفسي لأتمكن من إيجاد
جهة راعية تدعمني.
أريد السعي للحصول على منح رياضية
على مستويات أهم.
ولأزيدكم من الشعر بيت،
لأحدثكم عن أهم شيء، وهو نفسيًا،
نفسيًا، كانت ملجأ كبير جدًا لي،
من خلالها، كنت أفرّغ
كل الطاقة السلبية بداخلي،
كل الضغط،
كل كلام الأشخاص، المجتمع حولي، التمييز.
كُل ماذُكر كان يختفي عندما أبدأ بالتمرين.
كل ماذُكر يصبح من الماضي عندما تقفين
وتحققين إنجازات تحمل اسمك واسم بلدك.
في لحظة الانتصار،
صدقيني لن تتذكري
سوى الخيار الذي اتخذتيه،
والذي بسببه، أنتِ وصلتِ إلى هنا.
أنا كفتاة بالنسبة للمجتمع
مهما تطورت في هذه الرياضة،
سأبقى الفتاة التي تلعب “قتال شوارع“.
وإلى زملائي “أخت رجال“.
صدقوني سمعتُ كلامًا كثيرًا مثل:
من سيرتبط بك؟
إذا تشاجرتما ستوجهي له ضربة
تسببي له العَمى.
ولا يمكن أن أنسى ما أخبرني به زميلي:
“ماهذه هاللعبة، من المستحيل
أن أسمح لأختي بممارستها
لكي لا تفقد أنوثتها!
ها أنا أمامكم!
علا الفتاة التي ترتدي فساتين،
وتضع مستحضرات التجميل
وتقوم بالرسم وعمل المعارض.
هل ياترى أنني تجردتُ من أنوثتي حقًا؟
أم وجدت الشغف الذي أريد من خلاله
تحسين نفسي على جميع الأصعدة؟
أنا علا وأحبُ أن أخبركم:
دعونا نعيد التفكير في خياراتنا الغريبة،
والتي ممكن أن نختارها
سواءً على صعيدنا الشخصي أو المهني
أو حتى ممكن كتاب، هواية أو اهتمام.
أو كتير من الأشياء التي كل صبية
قادرة على أخذ فرصة منها
لتطور من نفسها
وتبني مستقبل مميز لها.
ما أريد قوله:
عندما تختاري اختياراتك الغريبة،
تذكريني،
وتذكري أنه ليس المهم كون خيارك غريب،
المهم
أن يكون مناسبًا لك.
(تصفيق)
شكرًا لكم!